PRICE.
>> Sean: GOVERNOR AND SPEAKER,
THANK YOU BOTH.
RUSSIAN LINKED HACKERS
DISRUPTING THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY.
AMERICA'S OIL AND GAS SUPPLY.
BUT DON'T WORRY BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS TACKLING
THE FOREIGN CRISIS THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION LIE.
BIDEN JUST HIRED SUSAN TO ITS
NATIONAL SECURITY DIVISION.
ALMOST NO ONE WAS MORE DEDICATED
TO PUSHING THESE LIES, THIS
RUSSIAN HOAX THAN SUSAN.
SHE HAD AROUND 39,000 TWEETS
DEDICATED TO THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION THEORIES.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
SHE LIED FOR 3 LONG YEARS.
HAWKING THIS LIE FOR 3 LONG
YEARS.
PUSHING THIS HOAX.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE SHOULD EVER
BE TRUSTED AGAIN.
NONE OF THEM.
THEY ARE LITERALLY CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS.
THEY HURT THE COUNTRY.
THEY LIED TO YOU DAY IN AND OUT.
RIGHT TO OUR FACES FOR POLITICAL
GAIN.
HERE WITH MORE IS SOUTH CAROLINA
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
I WANT TO SEE IF I UNDERSTAND
THIS.
TELL ME IF IS THERE IS
A CONNECTION.
JOE BIDEN FUNDS THE PALESTINIAN
AGAIN AND ROCKET FIRE INTO GAZA?
JOE BIDEN GETS RID OF THE DEAL
WITH IRAN AND THEY ALIGN WITH
THE RUSSIANS AND CHINESE TO
FIGHT A PROXY WAR.
DO YOU THINK THESE ROGUE NATIONS
SEE JOE BIDEN AS I DO?
DO THEY SEE JOE BIDEN AS WEAK?
DO THEY SEE HIM AS FRAIL AND
COGNITIVELY STRUGGLING?
>> THEIR ACTIONS INDICATE THEY
ARE NOT AFRAID OF THE UNITED
STATES.
EASTERN EUROPE COUNTRIES RUSSIA
INCLUDED ALLOWING CYBER
CRIMINALS TO ATTACK THE UNITED
STATES NEED TO PUT ON NOTICE,
CLEAN UP YOUR BACK YARD.
I LIKE NEWT'S IDEA OF CREATING
A CYBER-TERRORISM LIST.
WE NEED TO AMEND OUR LAWS TO
TREAT THEM AS TERRORISTS.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN MORE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY THAN
I AM NOW.
EVERYBODY SEES JOE BIDEN AS
WEAK.
GOING BACK INTO THE IRAN DEAL.
THE ARABS AND THE ISRAELIS ARE
BESIDE THEMSELVES.
CHINA THREATENS US AT EVERY TURN
AND RUSSIA HAS TROOPS ON THE
BORDER OF THE UKRAINE.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS TIME.
WHEN THE AMERICAN PRESIDENT IS
WEAK, THAT EMPOWERS ALL OF THE
BAD GUYS.
YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING EVERY DAY
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> Sean: YOU GOT HAMMERED ON
YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP.
I SAY CAN WE MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
WHAT DO WE CONSERVATIVES
BELIEVE?
LIBERAL, FREEDOM, CAPITALISM.
LOWER TAXES.
LESS GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY.
FREE AND FAIR TRADE.
SECURITY BORDERS AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND
CONSTITUTIONALISTS ON THE BENCH.
FREE MARKET SOLUTIONS TO
HEALTHCARE AND CHOICE THIS
SCHOOLS.
AM I MISSING ANYTHING?
IF I AM I NEED TO BE EDUCATED?
>> THAT'S A GOOD AMERICAN FIRST
AGENDA YOU DESCRIBED.
WHAT I SAID ON YOUR SHOW GOT
PEOPLE RILED UP AM IT'S COMMON
SENSE.
THE MOST POPULAR REPUBLICAN IN
AMERICAN IS NOT LIZ CHENEY.
IT'S DONALD TRUMP.
PEOPLE BELIEVE TRUMP POLICIES
WORK.
THEY ARE DISAPPOINTED HE LOST.
TRYING TO ERASE DONALD TRUMP
FROM THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
INSANE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR THIS PARTY
TO MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEING ITS
LEADER.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE CONSERVATIVES
HAVE CHOSEN HIM AS THEIR LEADER.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE HE DELIVERED.
THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL PRESIDENT
FOR NATIONAL SECURITY AND
SECURED OUR BORDERS.
THE PEOPLE CHOSE HIM.
>> Sean: I THINK TIM SCOTT MIGHT
BE THE SENIOR SENATOR NOW FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA.
AFTER THAT REBUTTAL TO BIDEN.
GIVING YOU A RUN FOR YOUR MONEY.
TAKING UNFAIR HEA